[Music]
the phrase couples goals is pretty
synonymous with Stefan Aisha what does
that mean to you I get it and we're
proud to take that in a sense because
we're not like it's pretty much what you
see is what you're gonna get and I think
that's oftentimes rare these days and so
it is nice that that's the case I mean
it feel pretty confident that we can
like uphold that oh yeah but but it's
don't see that all the time yet having
that friendship first is is so important
that foundation of communication and
openness and being able to talk to each
other and come to each other with what
ever it is is that that's going on it I
feel like the second that you forget to
stop and take the time to communicate
and like look each other in the eyes and
like have that time together and
peacefully together and laugh that's
when that's when you leave it so it's
always important to keep like that fire
that fire going and they're like a
favorite date night or just something
you always go back to I love those
nights with you know we get our kids
down a little bit early and they
actually go to sleep it's a dream come
true and then we wait to have that
dinner just together and we cook
together and we drink why and it usually
ends up being the whole bottle which I
write because we're at home the couple
has two daughters five year old Riley
and two year old Ryan are you supportive
of your kids entering show business you
think that no no no no never that I
think I think if they're ever if they
ever decide to go that route they have
to be like at the age where they can
make that decision for themselves
did they have similar personalities my
oldest is more headstrong and
adamant about about the students that
she makes when she's super sassy my
youngest is is just so gentle and sweet
but goofy and very very independent the
Curry's favorite activity cooking the
family of four spends a lot of time in
the kitchen of course using ayisha's new
cookware line one year you're giving
them kitchen confidence you're making
them feel accomplished and two there's
plenty of studies that show that if kids
cook with you and they have a hand in
making whatever it is they're eating
they're more apt to try it my two year
olds palate is actually a lot broader
than my five year really my
five-year-old I'll have to make her
pasta that has like butter and Parmesan
my two-year-old she has hot sauce
favorites I love it they couldn't be
more different it's it's hilarious
[Music]